so i've been watching a ton of curiosity  stream lately curiosity stream is a  streaming service just for documentaries  i love documentaries you can also watch  them on your tablet on your computer or  whatever device so i watched this film  called becoming martian and i know like  a little bit about the whole martian  idea going to mars and i had no idea all  of the different considerations for  actually putting humans on mars like i'm  not talking about the getting their part  the getting there we know is complicated  i mean once there all the things that  have to be figured out  fascinating becoming martian watched it  on curiosity stream you can get a  curiosity stream subscription for a year  for under 15 bucks not not per month for  the entire year  at curiositystream.com  david